having a guy like Garfunkel who sings
beautifully he's your security blanket
then we fast forward to when you finally
have had enough
and you know Artie's off making his
movies and he's not playing the game
with you anymore and he's keeping you
waiting in the studio that divorce that
you suddenly saying that's it I'm going
off on my own it wasn't already his
fault after we did The Graduate Mike
Nichols who was the director of The
Graduate said I'd like you both to be in
my next movie which is catch 22. right
so we were thrilled the next summer he's
called me up and he said you know we
wrote the screenplay and it's so long
that we have to cut out parts and we cut
out your character nice
already goes to do this and I was very
much in favor of him doing that in fact
I wrote a song about it The Only Living
Boy in New York right he's about him
going down to Mexico to shoot catch 22.
but like a lot of movies it just ran
over
and we were in the midst of making
Bridge Over Troubled Water and this was
interrupting your flow and Simon and
Garfunkel were at their Peak yep then
you know after The Graduate Artie was
understandably
excited about being in a movie with very
accomplished gifted gifted people what
what was going on in the studio though
was a a real tug of war about taste and
how to how to do it it wasn't just the
movie it was also
we didn't agree about you know we're
friends since since we were 12 years old
but our musical inclinations are quite
different and so
we would have disagreements and the
disagreements could be
you know real arguments that could stop
you know stop a session it's cold so
that was happening at the same time and
we were having to wait for Artie to get
released from from his shooting schedule
to come back to New York to start you
know to fill in meanwhile his head is
really in the movie which is
understandable I get it you know Chuck
Grodin who was in Catch 22 was an artist
friend and already introduced him to me
and Chuck and I became very good friends
Chuck said you know Artie is doing
Mike's next movie and I said no I didn't
know that Arty's doing Mike's next movie
was that carnal knowledge
so I said to Artie are you going to go
and do another movie now and he said
yeah and I said why didn't you tell me
I just heard it from Chuck Rhoden he
said I was afraid if I told you you
would stop working on Bridge Over
Troubled Water and I thought I gotta get
out of here yeah good for you when we
left well first of all I I I came up to
Clive Davis who was the who was the
president of Colombia and I said
uh I'm gonna leave and he said this is
the big that's the biggest mistake of
your life but he knows you know and I
said well you know maybe someday at the
end of my career people will say you
know and in the beginning of his career
he he was part of a Duo Simon and a
Garfunkel you know but Clive said look
you know I wish you good luck but as a
record company president that's it's
really a hard blow for me to lose
the biggest selling act that we have on
the label we would have broken up anyway
right uh Duos don't stay together don't
stay together